good evening my fellow americans all
righty folks today we'll be taking a
look at joe biden's first hundred days
in office what has he done wrong has he
done anything right
did he fulfill any of those lofty
campaign promises
find out in just one moment this video
is sponsored by raycon
so let's begin with covet 19.
we know what we need to do to beat this
virus
tell the truth joe biden promised that
he would release a vaccine distribution
plan
well actually what he ended up doing was
just using trump's vaccine distribution
plan
and then letting the states do what they
were already going to do and then jump
out in front of the parade and take
credit for it and remember that he
promised very early on that he was going
to put a million shots into arms
every single day 100 million shots
in 100 days they were already putting a
million shots into arms every single day
well now of course it's much higher than
that but that really has nothing to do
with joe biden as per our usual
arrangement come on give me a break
he also said he was going to listen to
science by rejoining the who and keeping
anthony pouch as a close advisor
well he did join the who and he did keep
vouchers as a close advisor
but these things are mutually exclusive
with listening to the signs considering
that joe biden
is now doing interviews in which he is
explicitly saying that he is not going
to do
what the cdc says you're allowed to do
if we were in fact sitting there talking
to one another close i'd have my mask on
and i'm at you to have muscle even
though we've both been vaccinated and so
which makes no sense it has nothing to
do with science whatsoever anthony fauci
continues to give
mixed advice about whether you should
mask or whether you should unmask
whether school should be open or whether
school should be closed
so if you want your schools to open get
your community level
down to a safe level anthony fauci has
been much more of a wall than a window
when it comes to transparency with
regard to covid
if you're going for a touchdown don't
spike the ball on the five-yard line
next let's get to the economy so he says
he's going to reverse trump's corporate
tax cut he hasn't actually done this yet
he's proposing to
raise corporate taxes through the roof
capital gains taxes through the roof
income taxes through the roof he is
going to raise taxes across the board on
pretty much everyone because it turns
out that when you tax corporations
you are taxing all the money that gets
passed down to the employees when you
tax capital gains you're taxing
investments in the stock market which is
going to lower
the increase in your 401k he hasn't
actually done any of this yet but he
certainly intends to do so
also joe biden pledged that he was going
to raise the amount of spending he's
doing
that he's definitely doing he's already
passed a two trillion dollar
useless package got it
thank you all he's going to pass another
two trillion dollar useless package on
infrastructure
and then he plans to pass another two
trillion dollar useless package
the american jobs plan so basically he's
going to spend 10 trillion dollars in
his first three months in office
if he gets his way and we'll see how
much that he can pass
when it comes to the environment joe
biden promised that he would organize a
climate world summit and he did
well hello again everyone welcome back
people got on zoom and they talk and joe
biden even wore a mask on zoom
which makes no sense because you don't
get coveted through the interwebs
during this climate world summit a lot
of people talked including greta tunberg
and let me just remind you greta is
disappointed in you how dare you
joe biden also promised to make the u.s
a leader on climate change i don't even
know what that's supposed to mean
it's just a lot of hot air no pun
intended
apparently that just means you hold a
bunch of world summits and then you make
a bunch of commitments that we're never
going to fulfill or even if we do
fulfill them it's not actually going to
radically change the increase in global
temperature that's
slated to happen over the course of the
next century but he feels really good
about himself and john kerry gets to use
a plane
we will get back to more on joe biden's
first 100 days but first
raycon is disrupting the electronics
industry by making great sound for
everyone their wireless earbuds started
half the price of other premium audio
brands
raycon earbuds they give you six hours
of playtime seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass
more compact design for that comfortable
noise isolating fit raycon
offers their wireless earbuds in a range
of fun colors and patterns they've got a
variety of fit options
no dangling wires no stems what i love
most about my ray comes again i can
customize them so they fit my ear
perfectly unlike the other sort of
one-size-fits-all options raycons are
great they fit my ear the way they're
supposed to fit and they have the colors
that i want what's not to like the
company was co-founded by ray j
celebrities like snoop dogg and brandy
love
raycons plus raycon has a 45 day free
return policy i will be taking these
babies
right here to the beach with me so that
i don't have to listen to my children
you will love raycons as well look they
fit so easily in your ear
go right in your ears
and now you are good to go click the
link in the description box or go to
byracon.com
shapiro yt to get 15 off your raycon
purchase
joe biden says that he was going to fix
racial equity problems in the country
here what he basically means is that
he's going to pervert the entire purpose
of the american government
so as to achieve equal outcome rather
than equal rights under the law
he has said that he wants to extend the
voting rights act which means basically
put the federal
government over all states that vote red
in the south and then demand that they
change their congressional districting
in a certain way is violative of the
supreme court ruling on the voting
rights act
has already been passed he says he's
going to push congress to pass the
george floyd act all that would do is
make it much much more difficult
to police also he wants to make sure the
doj can cram down
its version of settlements agreements on
every police department in a major
metropolitan area across the country
thereby
making it much more difficult to police
which of course will spike the crime
rates
he also says that he wants to push hr1
which is this
massive expansion of federal power into
voting procedures it is
blatantly unconstitutional but the basic
idea is if we can make it easier to
achieve voter fraud achieve ballot
harvesting somehow this will make voting
better in the united states on behalf of
racial equity or something
on immigration joe biden pledged that he
was going to make things better whoops
that didn't happen he said he was going
to stop family separations at the u.s
mexico border
nope we have more kids in cages than
ever before in american history
he said that he would defund continued
border wall construction didn't do that
in fact he's actually continuing to
build sections of a border wall he said
he's going to increase government
supervision
over u.s border and immigration agencies
not aware that he's done that all that
he's really done is incentivize
a lot of people to cross that border
illegally and then
he basically holds them for a while and
then he releases them into the interior
of the united states but don't worry
kamala harris is on it she is so on this
thing he assigned her
the border crisis she has spent
precisely zero minutes
at the border of the united states do
you plan to visit the border
not today on foreign policy joe biden
pledged that he would bring us back into
the community
of nations he pledged to pick up the
pieces of donald trump's broken foreign
policy here's the problem donald trump's
foreign policy was actually the best
part of his administration
his policy with regard to china was very
strong his policy with regards to the
middle east
ended with the abraham accords basically
it seems that joe biden's foreign policy
is
we will make nice with china ignore all
of their human rights violations in the
perverse hope that they're going to do
something about climate change
and then also he will make overtures to
the iranian regime which has
dedicated itself to the destruction of
the jewish state and the development
of nuclear weapons he's just relieving
sanctions for no apparent reason
on that front all the while ignoring the
progress that's been made in the middle
east between the arab countries and
israel trying to force israel to make
concessions to terror groups like hamas
when it comes to foreign policy again
joe biden really doesn't have a plan he
just has a series of impulses and his
impulses are all to kowtow to foreign
dictators as often as humanly possible
unless those foreign dictators were
somewhat nice to donald trump getting a
good picture everybody so we look
nice and handsome and thin
it's only been 100 days but joe biden
has radical change
on the mind the whole thing is that joe
biden was elected to provide stability
a return to normalcy moderation he's not
doing any of that he is going
full pedal to the metal on
all the radical left agenda items from
racial divisiveness
to economic blowout spending to
increases in taxes
to cow towing on american foreign policy
to some of the worst states on earth
culturally there are different norms at
each country
and they their leaders are expected to
follow get ready folks because it's only
going to get worse from here
you